- On this episode,
a legend stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- What's up everybody?
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 212 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
And as we can tell we have a
very, very, very special guest.
I'm not sure how for the four
people that don't know who you
are you're going to introduce
yourself for me from afar we're
just getting to know each
other but from afar music and
political icon is
where I put you my friend.
Wyclef, why don't you make
a little say hello to the
Vayner Nation before we get
into India's questions.
- Vayner Nation how you doin'?
My name is Wyclef
representing 212.
I used to do this in the
cafeteria all day, back in the
days I used to listen to NWA.
You don't know me man?
I'm from the Fugees
born in Haiti,
raised in Brooklyn, New York City
then moved to New Jersey.
- Jersey.
- It's natural. It's what
we used to do.
- By the way, I just want to say
if I could naturally do that I'd
have 17.9 million
followers on Instagram.
That's incredible.
- Wyclef to the
principals office now.
- When did you realize
you had that ability?
When did that first happen?
- Just the ability of words?
- Yeah.
- Man, being in a small
village coming from Haiti,--
- When did you come to the US?
- 10 years old.
- Yeah and I tell my daughter
like it's funny right 'cause she
gets everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, "You know your
dad was in Haiti," and then she
goes, "Oh, here goes
dad with the story
"that he rode a donkey
one time. The same story."
- But it's true.
I was born in Belarus in the
former Soviet Union we were came
here we were super poor.
My daughter just had a birthday
and I looked at my wife and
I said, "She just got more
presents on this birthday than
"I got in my life."
- Facts, man.
- I mean, that's
just the way it is.
- Yeah, man.
India, can you flow?
- No.
- You want to rap
battle with Wyclef?
- [Wyclef] India, flow, flow!
- That's not something.
- That's not where you're going.
- Too embarrassing.
- Why don't we start the show?
- Cool.
- And so, I tweeted out to let
people that you are coming--
- Yeah, man.
- so there's some questions,
business questions,
music questions I'm sure,
other questions.
Let's see where
people went. India?
- First one from Omar.
- Omar.
- [Voiceover] Omar asks,
"Making connections is a huge
"part of the music industry.
"For somebody who is
starting out, where do I start?"
- Oh man that's
a good question.
I think it's a little more
easier for you, Omar,
than it was for me.
- 100%.
There's a thing called
the fucking internet.
- Yeah. The internet is key.
Really for me we had to sit the
Fugees literally had to sit
through 7,000 A/Rs.
Saying this shit
ain't gonna work.
Like rappers playing guitars
and women singing and rapping?
No, no, no that's too much.
So with the internet you can
actually build your own audience.
- And you were going through
that process, I'm trying to
think back what that was
happening '91, two and three
before four and five?
93, 94 when it happened?
- Man, it was
going like '93, '94.
Do you know how weird it is
1993 a group shows up with an
acoustic guitar and we
tell them that we hip hop.
We from the 'hood.
And then you have one girl and
Clef grabs his and another kids
a rocker and I start playing
guitar and Lauren starts to sing
John Lennon "Imagine"
then I going to a freestyle.
Can you imagine somebody
who is A&amp;Ring that time?
- They didn't know.
- Do you know what I mean?
The beautiful thing about the
internet right here is that you
get to create your world.
And if your music or
whatever you're doing
is really original,
it's going to find its key
audience because through the
internet we've learned
it's a big universe, right?
You got your crowd.
- I completely agree with him
and I say this all the time.
The best way to sell is
for people to come to you.
The fact that there are things
now like Musically and Snapchat
and Instagram and all the other
platforms we know, the fact
you can actually produce music,
put it on Soundcloud and
actually serendipitously walk
into shit because somebody
heard it or shared it and
changed your world.
And that's just incredible.
People didn't have
that opportunity.
There are so many,
how many Fugees,
how many this is,
I'm dying to ask
you this question:
How many very
talented musicians
do you think did not get
discovered in the 50s, 60s, 70s,
80s and 90s because there was
just only some many A/R people,
they maybe live in Memphis,
they maybe lived in Haiti,
they lived in Belarus?
In your opinion do you believe
that if you were great it would
have just happened or do you
think in the 50s, 60s, 70s, 80s
and 90s a generation that we
don't grow up any more there
were actually real big-time
talents that never got their
opportunity 'cause they just
didn't have the being in the
right place at the right time?
- Yeah but you know what's
funny about what you said,
right, is you see
the music of the
50s, the 40s, the 60s, the 70s
was a different thing because
people wasn't worried
about show business.
- Right.
People was more
worried about--
- The music.
- the music.
- You see so this is how we
know of the Loneliest Monk.
This is how we could go
back to Muddy Waters.
- Mhmmm.
(Wyclef singing)
- It wasn't really about,
because think about it now.
Whenever we, this generation,
want inspiration as a producer
and we go out, I'm in the
studio with Avicci.
- Okay.
- Right.
And were sitting in
winter in Stockholm.
It's dark, right?
- Yep.
- We're sitting there and
we're talking about
chords and progressions.
What's the reference?
We go back to freaking
Ray Charles "Georgia."
- Mhmmm.
- At the end of the day, I just
think that we have to understand
that the idea of
the Fugees was musicality.
It wasn't like oh man we about
to do something to get put on so
people know who we were.
- Right.
- Man, if you listen to the
first Fugees album it's called
"Blunted on Reality".
The whole album starts out with
a poem where the Ku Klux Klan is
trying to come and invade this
generation and we talk about we
are not going for that.
- Allow that.
- Yeah.
If you trying to be in the music
business this is not the first
message that you
want to put out.
I think that the key to
everything whether if it's art,
whether if it's think of like a
Picasso when you
look at that piece.
Or of think of Basquiat when
you look at a piece or just the
Miles Davis "Bitches Brew" no
one thinking about so the idea
is we have to think
1,000 years from now.
Is this conversation
going to be relevant?
And I really think that's
my key with this generation.
And that's the only thing
that I tell them. I'm like,
"Yo, you're spitting out
hits. Every second."
Every second on Musically my
daughter is singing a new song.
Right?
- Yep.
- And the new one is
(signing in broken Japanese)
and then she puts
me on Musically and
she like, "Come on, Dad."
(laughter)
"No Dad. You're doing it
wrong, come back again."
- Yep. Third take.
- Third take and what
I notice is like 70 songs,
songs are playing and I say,
"Angelina, who's this artists?"
- She's like, "I don't know."
- She don't know but
she knows the song.
I think if we can push more
musicality to your point because
there are a lot of bad
ass artists out there.
They're on the internet,
you know what I mean?
We just got a
focus on musicality.
- Don't you think these
platforms give musicality
a better chance?
Because back to your point you
brought musicality and the human
being that was thinking business
is like, "Who wants this black
guy playing and the girl sings?"
Right.
- That's right.
- That's what stopped musicality
and now the open platforms
I actually think give
musicality a real opportunity.
- Yeah, sexy black guy.
- Respect.
- Yeah.
- Respect. Alright, India,
let's move this.
- [India] Next one's
from Alexander.
- Alexander.
- [Voiceover] Alexander asks,
"What are some essential things
"to do and to avoid when it
comes to personal branding?"
- From my standpoint
the thing it's so funny.
I make my parallels, I know you
probably don't know about this
backstory but I was in the wine
business and I came out and made
YouTube videos when YouTube
first came out and I talked to
people in
Springfield, New Jersey.
Not far from East Orange.
- That's right.
- In Springfield, New Jersey
in my office I made videos just
like this and I talked
to people about wine.
I told people wine tasted like
Whatchamacallit bars or when you
open a racquetball case.
Stuff that nobody
had ever done before.
There was no Wine Spectator or
Food Network that was gonna put
on this guy that compared wine
the Iron Sheik giving
somebody a Camel Clutch.
Nobody was going to put me on.
The internet put me on
and I think the
personal brand thing
is really no different
than musicality
a.k.a. real originality
a.k.a. actually having
the chops.
I think so many of you and it's
funny, you guys know, my crew
knows, I compare
entrepreneurship right now
to rap and hip-hop
because it's a genre that is
getting looked upon and all of a
sudden its fame and
it all the stuff and
you see a lot of
fake entrepreneurs.
That's the same thing as one
hit wonders just following the
melodies or the hooks that
work and there's nothing there.
I think the number one thing
to building a brand, a personal
brand, the number one to do
is to be you 24/7/365 forever
never waver regardless.
You know, money and
fame doesn't change you.
It exposes you.
It's binary one and zero, be
yourself 24/7/365 and the thing
not to do is alter that
in any shape or form? My man?
- Facts. Facts, man.
In hip hop we call that
you just spit some bars.
(laughter)
- I'll take it.
- Bars.
- Now I'm good.
I'm good.
- Bars.
- I'll take that put
that quote card everywhere.
- Bars.
- Alright, let's move it.
- [India] Brian.
- Oh video.
- Yeah.
- Good job, India.
(lively guitar music)
- Hey GaryVee, hey Wyclef,
how are you guys doing?
Thank you very much
for taking my question.
My name is Brian Ripps.
I'm a musician and
entertainer from New York City.
For the last 10 years I've been
making my living writing songs
and traveling the country
playing for the people.
One of the biggest lessons I've
learned is how to take no for an
answer and press on.
I'm curious to hear from both
of you what some of the biggest
no's that you been encountereed
in your career are and how
you overcame them and
moved on to conquer them?
- Great question.
- Oh that's good.
- It's very nice.
That was well done.
- Great guitar player, too.
- You know how happy
that guy is right now?
- [India] So happy.
(laughter)
- You killing that guitar.
He's in New York?
- [India] I'm not sure.
- Yeah, I think he said. Yeah.
- Yo, do me a favor
right now man--
- This is big.
- hit me at okay we're
gonna do, let's make this big.
(laughter)
- Now you gotta deal with this.
They have to deal with
this with me all the time.
I love it. Do it, do it big.
- Let's do this.
- Go ahead.
- When you come see me--
- In Jersey.
- We come chill, don't worry
I'mma have grass and everything.
- No worries.
- You bring the wine.
- I'm bringing the wine.
- So listen, why don't
we bring the homey in?
- Done.
- Let's bring him in.
Let's when Brian in and we
could do a little jam session.
Okay, that'd be cool.
So this is what I'm thinking--
- Dreams are made on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- To his question I would say
the no factor is a
motivation factor.
And the thing about it it's
goes back to what you said.
Every day you constantly
have to prove yourself.
- [Gary] Only as good
as your last at-bat.
- You're proving
yourself to yourself.
Always remember that because
the day that you wake up and you
say, "Man, I'm
already good on piano.
"I'm already good on guitar.
"I done wrote 50 songs.
"I don't need
to write anymore."
That's the day you're finished.
- [Gary] Finished.
- Because the thing that keeps
us as human beings going
is creativity.
The day that we lose that we
completely lose ourselves.
So to your point is it's just
about each one, teach one and
constantly being inspired and
whenever somebody told me no it
was always a motivation for yes.
- I couldn't agree more.
Again, so many of
you watch my content.
Only as good as
your last at-bat.
Chip on the shoulder.
I would say that I'm wired, I'm
curious, I'm surprised how much
I do want, I like
sticking it to the market.
I'm very competitive.
Do you find
yourself competitive?
- You have to be.
Naturally.
- To me I've talked a lot
about loving to lose.
I do.
For some reason, Staphon,
you know this when we play
basketball in the morning,
when I lose
I'm like weird.
I like it. There's a feeling
that I want.
It motivates me so much.
I truly believe that the thing
that separates so many people is
people are scared of
the no and the loss.
They think it's a scarlet letter
and what that does
it makes them not go.
I love the way
that he said,
"When I get no's I
push through."
For me, my early childhood to
answer you directly because
two guys that like to philosophize.
I'll go right into it, my
early childhood was
probably my biggest adversity.
I didn't have the same adversity
of being a minority or gender or
things of that nature.
I didn't have a whole lot of
money but the big thing that
I had I was getting Ds and Fs.
So I was making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards in the
malls of New Jersey but I was
getting D's and F's is a 13,
14-year-old and
everybody thought I was a loser.
My teachers, my friends'
parents because that's when
school was the game.
- Mhmmm.
- And so for me the market, the
world was telling me I wasn't
good and everything inside of me
told me I was going to be good.
I don't think you can be when
unless you love yourself first.
I think you're right about it
being a one-on-one game
inside your own dome.
So for me my adversity was
early on because once I hit the
market, once my entrepreneurial
flair came out my first year
running my dad's
business I grew substantially.
It was over before it started.
Adversity, I think the thing
that is most interesting to me
if this company doesn't do
well next year, if my next five
investments don't do well,
if my next prediction is that
Blah-Blah-Blah's going to be
huge and it isn't when then I'm
not as good anymore.
I'm fascinated by
the music industry.
Three, four good albums
in a row, iconic stuff,
one bad album.
It's amazing.
You're just as good
as your last at-bat.
- That's right.
Think about it.
In our business
we say 10 million is a
championship ring, right?
- [Gary] Okay.
- So to be able to
sell 10 million
a few times and to do it
for different people, right?
- [Gary] Yes.
- Not yourself.
- Because this is another thing.
Okay, cool, you can
make money but
can you make
other people money?
Because the key is if you can
make other people money, you
create social entrepreneurship.
- [Gary] That's right. Scale.
- That's right.
So for me that's
definitely part of,
so for me and my business
I remember I did the, when we
did "The Score" I got scared
after we sold 10 million.
- It's crazy, right?
- 'Cause I said, no
disrespect to Menudo.
But I'm not dissing you.
I love Menudo and
New Kids on the Block.
I love them
'cause they watching.
I love them.
But I was like, "Holy shit,
we're a pop group now."
- Yep.
- I disappeared man.
Got an apartment on
66th street and third
and I was in a small room.
And I was like, "I have this
thing called 'The Carnival,'"
and I was like, "I have
to do this thing."
- Now.
- And I was like,
"It's artsy, it's artsy.
I have to do this thing,"
and from there that landed me
Destiny Child,
Beyoncé and them. Right?
Somebody was like,
"Yo, we love 'The Carnival'.
"There's these four girls in the
hotel room and we need you to
"just go see them."
And then I went to this hotel.
- Let me ask you a
question about the hotel room?
Was that a moment where you just
understand immediately, did you
under immediately understand
Beyoncé had real big-time
talent or did that develop?
Just for you one-man,
I'm just curious.
Storytime.
- I think for me I have a knack.
Like Lauren as a kid 14, 15.
- She's from Maplewood?
- Yeah,
Maplewood, New Jersey.
- Right there.
- Columbia. Right.
So I get this gift
from the church though.
It's purely and the church
called me the choir director.
I can find a singer
in two minutes.
I'm like, "Well, this is the
singer that's gonna sing lead."
So definitely when I first
saw Beyoncé I was like wow.
Right?
- Mhmmm.
- What do I remember
about Beyoncé the most?
I'll tell you.
And she's watching, she know.
- Thanks for watching, B.
- Yeah. Every, every and
this is taking me back, right?
Destiny's Child was
opening up for me.
- Is that right?
- Right? Watch this.
But every time Destiny's Child
got off the stage and I went on
Beyoncé was
always on the side--
- Watching.
- studying the show.
People be like, "Man why
is she so invincible?"
She's so invincible because
she's a student of the game.
- She put in the work.
- Right?
This is another thing
when we talk about, right?
So for me when I show up
it's not about what I'm doing.
I want to know
what you doing. Right?
- It's actually, what I do
for living is actually only
predicated on watching what
other people are doing
to figure out what they're
going to do next.
You know, I'm going to stick
here and be selfish for a second
because it's the
thing I like the most.
Just binary, who, one man's
opinion, you're just one man--
- Yeah.
- Who was the most talented
person you came across and who
was the hardest working
person you've come across?
Right now, so far, in your
journeys, in your industry,
in your industry.
- So far, right?
- Yeah, just so far.
I'm just real curious.
And I know like I'm sure is not
what you think about everyday
and it might not come that easy.
As you debate it for me--
- For me it's a
set up question--
- Okay.
- Because I know Carlos
Santana watching this right now.
- Of course.
Carlos, thank you.
(laughter)
- We have a lot of
people to tweet.
- You're setting
me up right now.
But I could, you know,
it's just like
Santana's like,
"You better say me."
(laughter)
You put me on the spot.
- I know I'm putting
you on the spot.
- It's cool, it's cool.
But it's a good spot.
- But I'm curious.
You don't have to answer
but I'm really curious and
I actually I really want to know
hard work, I want the hard work
one to be honest with you.
- Everyone's gonna
respect this answer.
- Okay. Go ahead.
- For me,
the hardest working person that
I've came across in
my entire life so far
will have to be
Michael Jackson.
- Hmmm.
- Because and this is
why tell you, right?
So when you're hard working
your like moving at the speed of
light but somehow you're aware
of everything going on with the
culture and everything.
You know everything
at real-time.
'Cause you Michael, man.
You're like in Asia somewhere
so why are you calling me.
And then you're like, "Yo,
I was just watching this TV."
He's like, "Who's this guy?
Gone to November."
I think I am being pranked
and I hang up the phone.
The first time.
Michael calls back.
I'm like, "Holy shit, this
fucking Michael Jackson."
This guy is scheduled literally
shows every, every day somehow
finds time to
land at Sony studio,
come up the elevator,
come see me sit down and
that whole day changed my life.
Ever since that I just see
music totally different on the
perception because I'm like,
"Yo, this Michael Jackson and
he's sitting there normally,"
and he's giving me the rhythms.
While he's sitting there and I
know the dude is coming from,
the flight has to be super long.
And he's in there and he's like,
"No, this is how I'm
hearing the bass.
"This is how I'm
hearing the drums."
I'm hearing his whole body.
And I'm like, "Yo.
That's freaking Michael."
(laughter)
- Dude when I'm telling you
I'm tripping, I'm tripping.
So for me, I would say the
coolest, the coolest thing about
Michael, man so then we in the
room with two of us and
he's like, "Man, you know
your style reminds me
of when we were younger
they took us to Jamaica there
was a guy he used to smoke
a lot of weed."
(laughter)
"Bob Marley?"
He was like, "No, no, no."
I said "Oh, Peter Tosh,"
and he's like, "Yeah."
(laughter)
- That's unbelievable.
- So for me that to me--
- Was huge.
- It was huge.
And then I was amazed by the
short time that I spent with
Whitney Houston.
- Yes.
- She was insanely incredible.
Jersey.
- Yep.
- Jersey crew.
And, man, Whitney's
work ethics was crazy.
I guess I was lucky because when
Clive Davis calls you and
he's like, "Yo, man, I need a
song for Whitney Houston."
- Yeah.
- You start trembling, right?
And then Whitney shows up.
I'm like I know Whitney.
I know your schedule and
what you're going through.
Show up on 24/7.
- Ready to work?
- Insane.
Like it's the first record
they're being recorded.
And then you pinching
yourself you like,
"No, no. That's really Whitney.
'The Bodyguard',"
and then she showing
up as if this is the
first record she's
about to record.
- Because money and success
doesn't change you,
it exposes you.
- Facts.
- It's just so real. India?
- Bars.
- [India] The last question was,
"Who do you think the greatest
"hustler in the music industry?"
- Get out of town.
- [India] I'm serious.
- See I felt it.
- [India] Yeah, you knew.
You just knew.
- We're you just laughing?
Were you like this is so weird?
- I was just like this is great.
This is the flow. Obvious.
- The flow. The bars.
- [India] Yeah, the bars.
- Wyclef, what excites you about
tech, how old is your daughter?
- My daughter is 11.
- And so what is she about?
- So Musically,
she's all about it.
- She's about
everything tech related.
- She lives in the phone.
- As for as like audio,
yes, she lives in the phone.
- And what kind of
music does she like?
- Anything, she's eclectic.
She's like Clef's daughter.
(laughter)
But anything that is relevant--
- Yep.
- she puts me up on it.
Whether if it's like
from a DJ Snake remix.
- Mhmmm.
- "This is insane,"
To the Musically and this is
how it has to be adjusted,--
- Yep.
- to, "Dad," I don't know man,
"you have to challenge
Jason DeRulo
"to a dance
competition."
Do you know what I mean?
She so in tune.
- And what about for you?
What comes most natural?
Any of them?
Twitter, Facebook,
Snapchat, Instagram?
- What's funny is
to every social media
it goes with your
certain likeness.
- Mhmmm.
- So for me, the one that
naturally goes with me is the
one that can be
instant at real-time.
And that would be
Facebook Mentions.
- The live?
- The live.
- You love that?
- Yeah, I love that
because what happens is--
- Sometimes you'll just go on?
- Yeah it gives
the fan real time.
- Uh-huh.
- I'm all about 'cause sometimes
you're catching a vibe and you
want to give the fan that
exposure that they can only
catch that lightning
at that second.
- Yep.
- So for me I guess like for
DJ Khaled it's Snapchat.
- Yep.
- So my version of Snapchat
for me is Facebook Mentions.
- I love it.
- You know?
- Yep. I love it.
India, good show.
- [India] Thanks.
- [Gary] Wyclef,
I really appreciate it.
- Yo, so I'll see
you at the studio.
- 100%.
- Bars.
- What kind of
wine do you drink?
Are you into it yet?
Am I gonna educate you?
- Of course.
You can never stop learning.
You know what I mean?
- He's the best.
I love this guy.
He's just right, he's right.
- I look forward to being
educated, you know what I mean?
But shout out to my Russian
Jewish friends when you're
coming let me know because
I have a few wine boys--
- Okay.
- That are gonna show up with
something they brought
back from the caves.
- Okay, I love it.
- We gonna need your
opinion on some stuff.
- Alright, Wyclef every time we
have a guest they get to ask the
Vayner Nation the
question of the day.
Any question you want.
We'll get hundreds of questions
on Facebook and YouTube
answered for you.
Could be anything about music.
It could be what
you're thinking about.
It can be absolutely anything.
- Alright.
My question to the
Vayner audience
an elections coming up--
- Oh, going big.
- And Bernie started a movement
and clearly Bernie's not going
to be the candidate.
But Bernie's movement
has become so strong
that it becomes
part of America youth
moving forward movement
so my question
for you is how would
the candidate
that you choose that
you're going to continue with
the idea of free education the
different things that Bernie
is talking about, are you still
gonna be part of activating
your communities
meaning your mayors,
your Congressman, your statesman
on this movement
that has started?
And who are you basically
going to be voting for and why?
Wyclef wants a bloodbath
in the comment section.
- Yes, that's right, baby.
- I appreciate it, man.
You keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them.
What's up guys?
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Please do I get to
link it up anywhere?
Is it in here or
is it down below?
Is it in print or in my video?
- [Staphon] It'll be down
to your left.
- It's here down to my left?
Right here, there's a button for
them to subscribe to my
YouTube video?
Yeah it's that
little buggy thing.
That's right guys, click this.
That's right, use that.